-Welcome back.
Guys, it is time
for the "Watch It Once
TikTok Challenge."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ "Watch It Once
TikTok Challenge" ♪
♪ "Watch It Once
-I'm gonna need some help,
so joining me now is
the one and only Shakira!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, are you kidding me?
Come on. Shakira!
Come on, now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Uh...
-Hey.
-[ Chuckles ]
They love you, they love you,
they love you.
We love you.
Shakira, here's how this works.
Shakira and I are gonna watch
a TikTok dance once, okay?
We'll only get to see it once.
And we're gonna do our best
to re-create it.
Whoever's moves are the closest
to the original, wins the game.
-And who's gonna win?
-Hello, uh, whose show is it?
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-I've learned something.
Never underestimate your enemy,
so I know...
[ Laughter ]
...I have to be careful here.
-No, you don't.
I think you got this one.
But let's see --
let's see the first dance.
This song is by Duke & Jones
with Louis Theroux,
and the dance is choreographed
by Jess Qualter and
Brooke Blewitt.
-♪ My money don't jiggle jiggle,
it folds ♪
♪ I like to see you
wiggle wiggle, for sure ♪
♪ It makes me want to
dribble dribble, you know ♪
♪ Riding in my Fiat,
you really have to see it ♪
-Just once, really?
-Just once?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I know, I was hoping
the rules changed, too.
I was like, "Maybe --"
-Come on, one more time!
-Well, it's the "Watch It Twice
TikTok Challenge."
[ Light laughter ]
Uh, alright.
I think I -- Can I --
Let's just see it one more time.
[ Laughter ]
-Please?
-Please.
-Even for me it's just --
-♪ My money don't jiggle jiggle,
it folds ♪
♪ I like to see you
wiggle wiggle, for sure ♪
♪ Makes me want to
dribble dribble, you know ♪
♪ Riding in my Fiat,
you really have to see it ♪
-Alright, I got this.
Look, I'll go first.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I got this.
-I'm gonna go first,
I'm gonna go first.
I'll do it first.
Yeah, I'll go first.
-Okay. Okay. Be my guest.
-I'll show you how it's done.
Here we go.
Um, wait, wait, hold on.
Hold on.
[ Light laughter ]
Alright, so it's --
I think it starts with that,
right?
This is so embarrassing.
Why am I doing this?
Alright, and whenever
you guys are ready.
-♪ My money don't jiggle jiggle,
it folds ♪
♪ I like to see you
wiggle wiggle, for sure ♪
♪ It makes me want to
dribble dribble, you know ♪
♪ Riding in my Fiat,
you really have to see it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How could you?
-[ Laughs ]
That was too cute.
-Can you imagine me
at, like, a wedding?
What am I doing?
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ugh!
Alright, Shakira.
No one will ever
have to see that again.
It is your turn.
Do you remember it?
-I gotta bring my A-game now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. Wait.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Light laughter ]
-Here we go.
-♪ My money don't jiggle jiggle,
it folds ♪
♪ I like to see you
wiggle wiggle, for sure ♪
♪ It makes me want to
dribble dribble, you know ♪
♪ Riding in my Fiat,
you really have to see it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on. Oh, stop.
-Come on, that's not fair.
Come on, that's not --
Come on.
That's not fair!
You're Shakira. It's not fair.
-I'm very impressed by you.
I'm very impressed.
-You are?
-It wasn't bad at all.
-Let's watch them together
and see who got closer.
[ Light laughter ]
-♪ My money don't jiggle jiggle,
it folds ♪
♪ I like to see you
wiggle wiggle, for sure ♪
♪ It makes me want to
dribble dribble, you know ♪
♪ Riding in my Fiat,
you really have to see it ♪
-Oh, my God. Alright, no...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do we have to air that?
That is so emb--
I've got to make sure
my kids don't watch tonight.
That is so rough. Oh, my God.
Alright, let's try --
Let's try one more, okay?
Uh, I thought this would be fun.
The creator of this dance is
the one and only Shakira.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Singing native language ]
♪♪
-Ooh.
-Ooh!
-I like this. [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Alright.
-To be fair on this one,
I have a small advantage.
-Yeah, a "small" advantage,
yeah.
That was you.
Alright, let me see, here we go.
I mean, I think I can kind of --
alright, let me just do this.
I love it.
I love the jam, by the way.
-I need popcorn.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Just, let's get it over with.
Here we go.
-[ Singing in native language ]
♪♪
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Fanfare ]
[ Laughter ]
-This is so embarrassing.
It's so --
I can't even look at you.
I can't even look at you,
it's so embarrassing.
Okay.
-That was awesome!
-Okay. Oh, my gosh, alright.
-Wasn't he awesome?
-Oh, Shakira --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shakira --
-You remind me of my 6-year-old.
-I do? Oh, I -- Oh, good.
He's cute. I like that.
Okay, good, I remind you
of your 6-year-old.
Shakira, you are up. You're up.
Whenever you're ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Singing in native language ]
[ Crowd cheers ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are -- How do you --
Come on.
Who are you? Unbelievable.
Ugh.
-You know, I don't know --
-I'm so embarrassed.
-I don't know how
to dance in high heels.
I don't know how
-Alright, let's watch
the videotape
to see who got closer
of being Shakira.
[ Singing in native language ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
How embarrassing.
Look at that guy. Oh!
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, this, you nailed it.
-That's all I needed.
Stick the landing.
I think we know
who the winner is.
Shakira, ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Fanfare ]
Please don't put that
on the Internet, please.
That was amazing.
More with Shakira
after the break, everybody.